ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش ملفنا الثاني
مسعى مفاوضات سكيت البنادق في السودان ولا
تنطلقت في مدينه جده غرب السعوديه لم
يتحقق حتى اللحظه في المحادثات الاوليه
بين ممثلي القوات المسلحه السودانيه ودعم
السريع على ضوء مبادره صعوديه امريكيه
للتواصل الى وقف القطار والتواصل الى هدنه
دائمه وترتبط صعوبه المفاوضات باعتقاد كل
طرف بقدرته على حسب المعركه لصالحها التي
لا تزال مستمره نتحدث عن المعركه في مناطق
متعدده وتحديدا الخرطوم رغم الهدى ولكن
ورغم تحدي باقتتال المستمر على الارض تبقى
جلسات الحوار في جده فاتحه امدا لاحتواء
قد يحصل الخارجيه السعوديه عبرت عن امالها
بان يقود الحوار الى انهاء الصراع وانطلاق
العمليه السياسيه وعوده الامن والاستقرار
الى السودان مؤكده ان هذه الاستضافه هي
نتاج تكاتف دولي والتي تمت بجه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبشراكه مع
دول المجموعه الرباعيه والشركاء من الاليه
الثلاثيه من جهته كشفت امين العام بجامعه
الدول العربيه عن تشكيل الجامعات للجنه
تتكون من السعوديه ومصر والامير العام
للتوصل وللتوصل مع طرفي النزاع في السودان
والمجتمع الدولي في هذه الاثناء يناقش
مفوض الامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه
مع ممثلينا للجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
الذين يتفاوضون ايضا بشان هدنه جديده في
جده
الازمه السودانيه هو مبادرات الاحتواء مع
تفجر القتال حاولت الامم المتحده التوصل
الى تهدئه لكن دون نتيجه في السادس
والعشرين من ابريل مبادره ايجاد التي
تضمنت هدنه لمده 72 ساعه اضافيه كذلك
ايفاد ممثلين من طرفي النزاع الى جوبا
للتفاوض
رفض الجنرالان الحوار سواء داخل السودان
او خارجه في الخامس من مايو الرياض تعلن
عن مبادره سعوديه امريكيه تضمنت استضافه
ممثلين عن طرفي الصراع السوداني في جده
اضافه الى وقف التصعيد العسكري بين
الاطراف المتنازعه وانهاء العنف بشكل
مستقر وموثوق ايضا تهيئه الارضيه اللازمه
للحوار لخفض مستوى التوتر بما يضمن امن
واستقرار السودان وشعبه
[موسيقى]
نناقش مشاهدينا ومتابعينا هذه التطورات مع
ضيوفنا هنا في الاستوديو عثمان باني ريسو
تحالف قوه الخلاصه الوطنيه السوداني سيد
عثمان اهلا بك من القاهره لو معتصم العجبه
المحلل العسكري وعضو تجمع قدام المحاربين
السودانيين اهلا بك معنا واسمح لي ان ابدا
هنا في الاستوديو مع الاستاذ عثمان استاذ
عثمان رغم الهدن او اعلان على الاقل هدى
رغبه المبادرات رغم الوسطات الاشتباكات لا
زالت مستمره والاقتتال مستمر من يتحمل
المسؤوليه ذلك
ولا نشكرك على الاستضافه وابرك
نحيه
ضيفك من القاهره وايضا نحيه مشاهدينا عبر
خلف الشاشات
هو بالحقيقه هذا الصراع
الاعلى اللي حصل بين القوتين هم كانوا جهه
واحده دعم السريع جزرات الجزاء من القوات
المسلحه
والان بافعال اخرى يعني ما تمت نحن الان
نرى انه لابد ان تغيب هذه الحرب ولا بد ان
يتم انه سحب المقاتلين والوصول الى بائده
المفاوضات
يعني لحل هذا الاشكال
انك تقول ان الضامه السريع جزء لا يتجزا
من القوات المسلحه نعم هو قلت اليوم في
الواقع كان هناك تصريح خليني فقط اذكر
بهذا التصريح كان تصريح لمجلس لرئيس مجلس
السياده الانتقالي عبد الفتاح البرهان
يقول فيه بانه وجود قوات الدعم السريع في
مؤسسه معرقل هو لا يعترف في هذه المرحله
بوجودهم وهناك عوده عن الدمج بل ويعتبر
بان الوجود معرقل هو بالحقيقه يعني اي طرف
الان ممكن يعني يتحدث باي لغه يمكننا
الناس هم يعني في حاله حرب ولكن الدعم
السريع هو اساس 2017 بين مرسوم يعني انشاء
الرئيس السابق ومعروف يعني والدعم السريع
جزء لا يتجزا من يعني بمهام نوع من الرواه
المسلحه وكذا وهو بمهام محدوده والان قائد
الدعم السريع هو يعني كان بيتغلد يعني في
السابق
ولكن في هذه المرحله وهذه المرحله خطيره
وهذه مرحله فيها تصعيد خطير من يتحمل
مسؤوليه استمرار الاشتباكات هذا هو السؤال
استاذ عثمان
هو مش يعني مثلا يعني من يتحمل الان نحن
اصلا لو في تحمل هم الاثنين يمكن يعني
الناس ولكن نحن الان نرى انه نصل يعني
للاجابه لسؤالك ده لازم يكون عبر ماده
المفاوضات الان الوفدين في وفود الان
موجوده في جده في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه برعايه سعوديه امريكيه ولكن نحن
يعني رؤيتنا ان هذه الرعايه يعني كانت
منغوصه لانه هنالك الام مبادره مع الاتحاد
الافريقي في مبادره مع جامعه الدول
العربيه فبالتالي لابد ان يتم يعني اشراف
كل هذه المبادرات في منصه واحده ايضا
المفاوضات يعني حسب قراءه حضرتك الحل هو
في الجلوس وفي التفاوض خليني انقل فقط
لنشرك معنا ضيفنا كذلك من القاهره ومعتصم
هل تتفق مع ضيفي بانه الحل الاساسي في هذه
المرحله حتى وان استمرت الاشتباكات هو في
الجلوس هو في المفاوضات هو في جده
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الرحمه
والمغفره لكل شهدائنا سواء كان من القوات
المسلحه او من الدعم السريع فهم خصم على
الوطن
والرحمه والمغفره
للشهداء الذين سقطوا في هذه الحرب المدنيه
من الابرياء نتيجه للغزائف ونتيجه
هو نهايه اي حرب يعني على حسب التاريخ لحد
الان اي حرب بتنتهي بمفاوضات
وبتبتدي هودنا بعد الهدنه بتبتدي
المفاوضات بيبتدي فصل القوات
ده ده شيء عادي في الحروب
طاوله المفاوضات هي شايله ولكن في اي
مرحله سياتي بمعنى في اي مرحله ستتفق
الاطراف على الجلوس منذ قليل اسمح لي كنا
نناقش الملف السوري وطاوله مفاوضات الملف
السوري انتقلت عبر العواصم واستمرت لاكثر
من عشر سنوات المشكله في طاوله المفاوضات
ام في الاطراف
هو ده لازم يعني وقف الحرب الحرب لانها
بتدور في مدن يعني ما عندها اي مناطق
ثانيه غير مدينه
او العاصمه المثلثه اللي هي بحري والخرطوم
كويس ودي عصب السودان يعني
بنتكلم عنه دلوقتي
عدم وجود الرعايه الطبيه عدد وجود الغذاء
حيبتدي بعد شويه الوقود ينفذ يعني حتكون
مقاسي شديده جدا
العدم وقوف الحرب ده لانه الحرب دي اساسا
ما في تحضير لها كان يعني الشيء الوضع من
سير القتال انه الطرفين ما كانوا جاهزين
للحرب دي
الطرفين ما كانوا جاهزين للحرب ذي
معقول
تعتقد حقيقه تسمعني
طيب تقول حضرتك بان هذه الحرب لم يكن محضر
لها تعتقد حضرتك فعلا بان هذه الحرب لم
يكن محضر لها خاصه وان هذه الازمه سبقتها
ازمه ثانيه ازمه تصريحات تصريحات فيها
تصعيد كبير بين الجنرلين
التصعيد الكان حاصل كان خلاف سياسي ابعد
من انه خلاف عسكري يعني ما كان في انشقاق
او واضح انه في انشغار بالعكس كان في
خلافات في حول
الوثيقه الدستوريه وصلوا اخر ايام اخر
يعني اخر مرحله اللي هي كانت الورقه
الخامسه المفروض انه تدمج القوات
يعني الخلافه اللي حصل ذلك خمسه يوم
مندمجه دمج القوات الدعم السريع في في
القوات المسلحه
حضرتك اللي هو معتصم وضحت الفكره ولكنك
تطرح نقطه سانقلها لضيفي ومعتصم يقول بانه
هذه الحرب لم يكن محضر لها طيب ان اعتمدنا
هذه القراءه حرب لم يكن محضر لها يعني
ليست هناك حسابات مبدئيا لكل طرف
انهاءها سيكون صعب لانه طالما ليست هناك
نقاط ليست هناك اهداف يراها كل طرف
فالامور ضبابيه فكيف ستنتهي هذه الحرب اهو
بالحقيقه يمكن يعني اي حرب يعني لازم
تنتهي عبر بائده المفاوضات حتى لو طلب او
غسرت ايضا اهم حاجه العامل الرئيسي هو
يعني الاراده لابد ان تكون هنالك اراده
واليهود هذه الاراده هو المكون الداخلي في
المقام الاول ان يكون المكون السوداني
السوداني
لانه نحن الان يعني راينا
عده مبادرات موجوده سواء من الاتحاد
الافريقي او جامعه الدول العربيه او
الاوروبيين او الامم المتحده ولكن رؤيتنا
انه لابد ان يتم هذه المبادرات كلها وضع
في منصه واحده وتنطلق من قاعده واحده منصه
واحده بمفهوم واحد وايضا لابد ان يكون
هنالك
خارطه الطريق ليس فقط يعني يتفاوضوا على
على استمراريه الهدنه فقط او وقفت
الاختطال الان في يمكن خمسه هدن يعني كانت
موجوده طيله الاسبوعين المضو هذه الهدنه
يعني حصل فوق اختراعات
وهذا واسطه عليه ودعم السريع ام لابد ان
اقترحتم نحن اقترحنا
لا هو الوسيط ما جاوبنا مش يعني هم
الطرفين الوسيط ما جاوبنا نحن الان في
يعني نحن الان قدمنا مبادره مبادره الخلاص
الوطني والطرفين موافقين عليها ولكن
الوسيط الان نحن طرحناه للوسيط ومنتظرينها
على رد الوسيط نرى انه الان الاخوه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه عشان ما يعني
يضيع الوقت لابد اشتراك القوى السياسيه
وايضا هذه المبادره ما تكون ناقصه على
مراحل لابد ان تكون مبادره شامله كامله
يعني تبدا من وقف اطلاق النار واستمرار
بالمراحل المتعدده خلينا نتحدث بطريقه
واقعيه حضرتك تقول بانه يجب ان تشارك
القوى السياسيه نتحدث مثلا عن الحريه
والتغيير هو من اكبر الاحزاب السياسيه
الموجوده في داخل السوداني طيب كيف سيشارك
وهو اساسا منقسم بمعنى انه هل سيتمكن
الحريه والتغيير من
محاوله تجاوز خلافاته هو والتعامل مع هذه
المرحله بما يمكن الاطراف من التقدم او
نحو تهدئه كامله ونحن نتكلم على الحريه
والتغيير الاولى منصه التاسيس الاولى ل
هؤلاء هم اللي فوضوهم الشعب السوداني نحن
الان ما زلنا في طور يعني ثوره ديسمبر
لانه نحن الان هذه المرحله المرحله
الانتقاليه فبالتالي ثوره ديسمبر هي
المفوضت فوضت قوه معينه وفوضت القوات
المسلحه بالدعم السريع فبمجيبه حصل انه
يعني ادخال القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
في هذا
الوثيقه الدستوريه تم التوقيع عليها
والتوافق عليها نحن الان رؤيتنا لحل هذا
الاشكال شامل كامل يتم عبره الوثيقه
الدستوريه عبر مائده المفاوضات وتكون شراك
القوى السياسيه الاولى لمنصه التاسيس لعام
اما لواء معتصم ما رايك ضيفي يطرح فكره
وجوب ان تشارك القوى السياسيه
لاصفاء شرعيه وكذلك حتى لبناء خطه لانه مش
وقف الاقتتال فقط هو المهم ولكن ان تكون
هناك خطه مستقبليه
في الحقيقه مشاركه القوه السياسيه
واجبه لكن ما في المرحله دي المرحله دي
بتستوجب اول حاجه وقف اطلاق النار ودنه
بعد الهدنه وقفه كامل لاطلاق النار
ترتيبات بتاعه فصل القوات فصل تام واخراجه
من المناطق المدنيه شغل ولكن لم يتم ذلك
فقط لافهم من حضرتك ومن خبرتك العسكريه
حضرتك عسكري لما تكون هناك هدنه ويتواصل
الاشتباك ما الذي نفهم
كنودنا وتواصل الاجتباك معناها ما في خطوط
ما في مراقبه ما في مراقبه ما في مراقبين
كل المناطق بتاعه التماس وزي ما قلت لك دي
حرب بمدن المراقبه بتاعتها صعبه حتى يعني
انت عايز كميه بتاعه مراقبين
دوليين او غير منحاهزين يعني
او من
الاقليم او
الناس يكونوا محايدين بيعرفوا في اللحظه
الفلانيه من الموقع الفلاني طلعت لكن
دلوقتي هو الحاصل الليله القوات دي مشتركه
في شوارع وازقه
فصعب جدا لازم يحصل في الاول فصل القوات
المفاوضات نفسها
القوات يحصل لها انسحاب من المواقع
الحاليه بتاعتها على اساس انه تسهل عمليه
الهدنه مراقبه الهدنه
يعني بكون في وقفه اطلاق نار بيكون في
هدنه
القوه السياسيه ممكن تخش بعد المراحل
بتاعه الهدنه الكامله او وقف القتال ممكن
تخش المرحله دي في المرحله دي ممكن تتشاور
مع الوسطاء مش مع الاطراف بتاعتنا يعني
الاطراف الناس بتحسهم في وسائل التواصل في
الاجهزه الاعلام في الصحف لا للحرب يعني
رفعته بعض كل
الاحزاب وكل الطوائف يعني ما في حد واقف
مع الحرب ذي لا للحرب لو في خلاف الواقع
صحيح وقال لها الجنرالان قالوا
المنتصر في هذه الحرب خاسر مهما يكون شكل
هذا الانتصار استاذ عثمان
صحيح صحيح استاذ عثمان ما المتوقع من
مبادره
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو
بالحقيقه يعني اخذ اختبص منك جملتك
الاخيره اللي هي الكلمه بتاعه الطرفين
اللي قالوا الرابح او المنتصر بهذه الحرب
هو الخاسر لانه هم الاثنين يعني ابناء
السودان وابناء الوطن
ويعني الخاسر هو الوطن وخاسر هو الشعب
السوداني لانه هذا الابناء والدمار الحصل
يعني كل دمار الشعب السوداني نعم ولكن نحن
الان هو نحن الان نمثل القاعده الجماهيريه
فبالتالي الان الخسران الوطن اي يوم بتاع
استمرار في مزيد من المعاناه للمواطن
السوداني
فانا ارى يعني من هذا المنبر واناشد الان
السيد قائد الدعم السريع بسحب مقاتلينه
الان فورا والاعلان رسميا على وقف اطلاق
النار
وسحب مقاتلين رسميا
في هذه الحاله بيكون هو اول حاجه قدم يعني
المبادره واتقدم خطوه وخطوه حسنه وفي
الطريقه السليمه
وتحسب له وشيء ايجابي في يعني في خطواته
هو ثم بعد ذلك وتكون في اليه موجوده السيد
الضيفك الكريم من القاهره هو ذكر انه تكون
في قوات اساسا لو في قوات القوات اللوتات
يعني راح تكون طبعا لمين هل طبعا يعني
لاحد الطرفين ولا قوات مثلا امميه نحن ما
دارينا الملف انه يصل لقوات اوباميه ويتصل
للملف يعني يصل للدول مثلا
يجب ان تكون الحلول داخليه على كل انا
ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر الوقت انتهى مش
لانه الاسئله انتهت ولكن اكيد باننا سنبقى
في متابعه كل هذه التطورات لاحقا عثمان
رئيس تحالف قوه الخلاص الوطني السوداني
شكرا لك وشكرا كذلك لضيفي من القاهره لو
معتصم العجبه المحلل العسكري وعضو تجمع
قدامه المحاربين السودانيين شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات